in 2020 cocoa farmers in ivory coast
were dealt a heavy blow as exports fell
due to covet 19. the pandemic hit
almost immediately after the world's top
producer announced an increase
in farm gate price hundreds of farmers
were left with beans they couldn't
export
but the pandemic also opened new
opportunities for farmers like onjawaku
sa serenbon initiative local processing
has been a very good idea
as we've had local cooperatives that buy
and process the beans
this is helping us to sell our produce
more
like many other farmers he's looking to
earn more than the 3
of the 100 billion a year industry
factory owners like axel emanuel are
expanding
looking to cash in on the new
opportunities
since one century we're planting cocoa
growing cocoa
but the main people there do not know
don't know how the chocolate is made how
to process
when you process there is many value in
the value chain the remaining
opportunity to earn more money the
chocolate the the cocoa
is around one dollar per kilo is very a
good abstraction
when when you process you can earn more
and
all our cocoa is coming about but now
with this seed we decide to process here
the government is happy to encourage the
increase in local processing
with its multiplier effect on the local
economy
for decades farmers and the ivorian
government were focused on exporting raw
cocoa beans for foreign exchange
but producers are now realizing they can
get more out of the beans
than just foreign currency
atumori valentine iowa and other
villages are taught how to extract oil
and butter
from cocoa until now she was unaware of
the opportunities in processing the
beans
before the surge in local processing
activities all the beans are sold after
harvest by the men
they kept the money but with this
transformation we too are getting
additional income to support ourselves
and the family
the cocoa oil she extracts is used for
cooking
and costs more than other cooking oils
cocoa butter is also an important
by-product
which the country used to import from
the same cocoa beans it exports
the newly acquired skill is expected to
drastically reduce the import of finnish
cocoa product
usually brought in at a higher cost
despite the inward looking measures few
expect output from the world's biggest
cocoa producer to fall
instead officials are hoping to boost
production far beyond the over 2 million
tonnes harvested
in 2020 mohammed idris al jazeera
abigail